this is what met firefighters a town
ablaze it is one thing even to drive
through this terrifying unpredictable
fire there's another to confront it
head-on on foot carrying just a hose
this unbelievable bravery is being
repeated around Australia after the
chaos and fear of Monday and Tuesday
today the counting neighborhoods
destroyed houses burnt to husks are
siding forward yeah but I decided
anybody don't stay just go the Meissner
high just go just go
just what you do is put your life at
risk there's now no need to just go just
get out and go for those who did get out
in good time it has still been more than
hard Kevin and Kathy Clark have been
camping at this relief center since
Sunday we're not sure there's people get
the reports but then they hear something
else we've been up and down on the
emotional scale a fair bit I hope the
last few days so there's not a lot we
can do about it it's probably we
probably won't know the full extent of
how much of it's gone until you know
they open the roads and we can go back
in today the relief efforts could begin
in earnest people in this community come
in to donate whatever they could to take
it to a town called buckin decimated by
the bush fire the people there
desperately needed water and supplies
the area is under strict control for
safety reasons so behind me that way is
buck and it is still threatened by a
farm that's why there's a police cordon
here they're not letting anyone through
apart from residents and emergency
services because it's still dangerous
but you can see that conditions are
better today it's a lot less windy it's
a lot less hot so that offers the chance
for two things first of all to reach
those communities like buck in the have
been isolated get them supplies but also
to prepare to try and contain the fires
ahead of what comes on Saturday because
people fire officials are worried that
what comes on Saturday is going to be as
bad or even worse than what we've seen
so far this week has already proved the
most lethal in four months of bushfires
this is what the fires leave behind them
and they're still burning tom Cheshire
Sky News East Gippsland